what we ask our clients is uh three
questions
and you gotta look them right in the eye
and say
what do you want michael what do you
want
and your thoughts are going through your
mind already but then we gotta pause and
say no no no michael
what do you really want that you would
make sacrifice for
because you can't have everything what
do you really want
and then why do you want it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders and meet mike watson the
president at ignite management services
and he is the co-author of rise up
leadership habits for turbulent times he
is on a mission to change how business
is done by encouraging leaders to adopt
the habits of resilient leadership he
has embraced the journey of pursuing the
best version of himself and helps
leaders do the same to be more inclusive
inquisitive and humble mike's personal
goal is to make the world a better place
one interaction at a time this has
guided him in many roles including
directorships at all levels of chambers
of commerce in canada
i'm really excited to talk to you about
your you know your journey your career
your thesis around leadership and
especially leadership through turbulence
rise up the book that that you wrote and
um talk a little bit about how your your
personal career and your own journey
you know works in conjunction with these
ideas and these thoughts that you're
sharing with the world about leadership
um as director of the canadian chamber
of commerce and the president of ignite
management services
so mike tell me a little bit about where
you're at in terms of your career and
how that plays into
this higher level thinking of what good
leadership is
yeah thanks uh michael i'm going to
start with a quote that we use to raise
our children it's wisdom doesn't grow on
our good days um and i i'd say that i
i'm where i am today through a series of
happy accidents
um and and perhaps an element of
serendipity i started my career in
banking and i would say had the fortune
and misfortune of being reasonably good
at it uh because i i ended up being
there longer than i should have it was
inconsistent with my personality but it
also proved to be an incredible training
ground on how to lead but more
importantly how not to lead uh which
when we when we wrote the book rise up
leadership habits for turbulent times
it's it's told through the lens of the
mistakes i've made my colleague has made
and a lot of vulnerability in there uh
which is because we got to this place of
leadership through the school of hard
knocks and i think the the biggest one
in strategy
is i was an executive a young guy young
man in in
in a fairly good larger mid-sized
financial institution with the role
to transform the brand the culture the
operations of this entity
and you can imagine 30 second-year-old
guy eagle out the ying yang hey i was
pretty proud of myself and so i wrote
this strategy i researched it it was
awesome to this day i'll tell you it was
the best strategy i've seen took it to
the board they said oh my gosh my guts
brilliant they applauded they said
that's wonderful and then we launched
michael we launched it and in banking
financial service you have financial
margin you have fee income you had
customer satisfaction you got employee
engagement and so change expect a little
bit of a down tick okay we were ready
for that month one downtick month two
downtick month three doubting six three
months we were going down
and uh i was leading headed towards the
most catastrophic failure in my career
and i looked to a colleague of mine who
i trusted and who i really trusted and i
said mike i said to her what's wrong
like why don't they get it hear the
words why don't they get it it's all
about you know me and what i want and
they should just do that run along with
me she looked me right in the eye she
says you know i said i don't know she
says you know
she says i said please tell me she says
mike they can't stand you
they can't stand you
you got an ego that is massive you don't
listen you're always telling people what
to do
and that michael in that moment in time
first i wept i mean this was a crushing
blow but then there was a pat now there
was a problem to be solved and we could
that's when we learned that strategy
without leadership will fail
and that was the most critical lesson in
my career and that's what got us on the
path that we're on today
so you know a lot of times and and with
some other episodes as well you through
this show it seems like a really big
part of this transition
to to learn from these lessons and to
become a better leader you have to first
accept and adopt the idea that you're
making mistakes as a leader
and you know the leadership style that
we currently have is not necessarily
working what was that experience like
for you you're mentioning this below
right and you know your world is shaking
but was it a really a single moment in
time where sort of all of a sudden you
saw the world in a different light or
was it a process you had to go through
to understand yeah
that it's not working
yeah it was it a grand epiphany that
changed everything
i i would say it was a moment in time
that said there's a need to change
and in this case it was a pretty
significant moment and need to change
but we get presented with those every
day you know we're running a business we
know a meeting hasn't gone that well the
need to change is put in front of us
quite regularly
what was the harder part was the
willingness to change
because i spent a career doing business
a certain way and had a modicum of
success
so it was the willingness to change that
came over time but even still
because these are habits that form
michael it wasn't that wasn't enough
it's because i'd i default back you know
set back set back and and go back where
where i was before
it wasn't until there was a deeper
motivation to change unless we talked to
leaders about
listen to the cues that it's not working
quite as well as it could have or should
have
then developed though i choose to be the
best version of myself but then equally
important why
why do i want this because in the
absence of a profound why
we will go back to where we started
habits are incredibly
difficult to form
and without the purpose behind them they
falter
right are there different specific
strategies of of asking this why
question or
measuring it's
it's you know how how meaningful it
actually is or how found how grounded it
is because any of us regrettably you
make a quick excuse as to why we're
doing something
yeah uh you froze on me for a bit so i
think i i heard the question and and how
what tools might you use
uh what we ask our clients is uh three
questions
and you got to look them right in the
eye and say
what do you want michael what do you
want
and your thoughts are going through your
mind already but then we gotta pause and
say no no no michael
what do you really want that you would
make sacrifice for
because you can't have everything what
do you really want
and then why do you want it so there was
a ceo we were working with who was was
wrestling and he had unbelievable
successes
you know they were winning winning
winning winning and yet he was always
miserable
and
what's up with this and so i asked of
those three questions and that was it
for a week i didn't talk for a week and
the next week he said i gotta be honest
he said i'm unfulfilled
i'm unfulfilled and it just opened the
floodgates he said
that those questions brought me back to
my childhood we were a family that moved
city to city military family and city to
city said i'd make friends i'd lose
friends i'd make friends i lose friends
he says as i got into the workforce like
he says i became a leader who looked at
people as assets to be deployed but not
relationships to be fostered and he says
so we've had these successes but i stand
alone
there's no fulfillment
what do i really want he says i want
psychological freedom that says i'm part
of something bigger
i want to look up these relationships so
that the unlocking tool is what do you
really want
and and the message is that that emerges
from that bigger than yourself
right now are these usually you know
single conversations of what you want
and why do you want it and these are
sort of meant to last for a long time
how often do we actually revisit
this you know this then it's theoretical
notion
of
why do we do what we do right now i want
to
be a leader of this organization because
of x y z how do i know to ask myself
when this may change
yeah and and i think it's be open to
change
and it's you can't look to where you're
going to be when you're 65 years old
with where you're at today you have a
general sense of what it looks like
right but i think we need to be open to
that allowing that to change and asking
ourselves that on a consistent basis
but if if we step back and say what do i
choose and it's to be the best version
of myself
and that's non-negotiable i will be the
best version of myself we work i don't
know if you're a soccer fan we worked
with the coach of the men's canadian
national soccer team there's there's a
great qualifying run for the world cup
and john erdman and what he says is be
at eighty percent of your best a hundred
percent of the time
to to be on that journey of self
improvement best version yourself
because 80 percent yes a hundred percent
of the time and then peak when you need
to peak
and then be open to your life
circumstances will change
in sports you'll see an athlete whose
physical capability declines so they're
going to change position or change the
way they play the game
you have a young person in their start
of their career
single and nothing but time and energy
and passion then they have children or
family a partner
and so now your priorities change but if
you're committed to the best version of
yourself you're going to shift with that
right
i love that so
that's also one of the key takeaways
here though this general idea of this
self-improvement is the route of
altitude to being to becoming a better
leader and specifically within the
self-improvement domain this
intentionality behind asking ourselves
the what and the why and and this idea
of the of of being consistent and i love
the idea of being 80
of your best 100 of the time i think
that's fascinating you mentioned
some downfalls that you've observed and
how not to lead and one of the things
that i've always crucified you know
there's a lot of you know different
faces about how to become a good leader
i'm curious about how to identify a bad
one how do i know to wake up and say wow
i'm not operating as the right leader i
can be or somebody on my team one of my
vice presidents in my startup isn't
exemplifying the leadership that i want
in my company how do we how do i know
that what are the best practices
um first off how do i know i'm not the
best leader i can be is i accept it
right now i'm not the best leader i can
be period
don't ever think you are because you're
not there's not one of us that is the
best version of ourselves that's a
lifelong journey and it sounds subtle
michael but but it it's once we accept
notionally as in as individuals we are
not at our best it focuses our mindset
on being our best and it opens us up to
feedback from others
so then once we accept that it creates
conversations i i had a
regular chats with the the woman that i
co-authored the book with ellie this
brilliant gifted leader and she i was so
fortunate that she joined me and i'd
watch her sometimes with be and she'd
get that look and that look would say
mike
you're not at your best
but i can't be
conscious that i'm on this journey to be
receptive to that look but even worse i
had to ask her for her feedback this
woman who reports to me where i'd pay
her salary i had to be receptive to her
feedback and i got to tell you
i got ego like everyone else it isn't
easy to accept
but so then we would become receptive to
the feedback but then transition you
also said how does the leader who's
looking at a peer group and saying one
of my colleagues or people that reports
to me isn't being the best version of
themselves the the piece and it was kim
scott's book um uh radical candor i take
so much value from and it's
care and communication radical cater you
you speak the truth but always let them
know you care about them first
and i but michael i care deeply about
you and your success and that's why i
want to have this conversation which is
going to be hard for both of us
and be inquisitive
it's it's when people know you care
uh trust is formed and when trust is
formed we can communicate more openly
and then interestingly kim scott calls
it out people would rather someone that
tells them the truth
without care then somebody cares so much
they won't even tell them
now that's fascinating i would rather
work with
uh somebody who's we would be described
that the letter starts with a and ends
in e then somebody who cares so deeply
about me that they won't tell me the
truth
right
it's i think that the whole
the whole thinking process of of the
people that you surround yourself with
and you know this whole culture of
feedback and how do we actually give
proper feedback i think that it it
sounds like it's overlooked a lot of
times this simple yet critical
part of of a company of a group how do
we give feedback to each other
especially when it's hard feedback and
you know that's the important feedback i
think we don't need more people to tell
us how good we are and how we're doing
things the right way right i mean and
unfortunately i'm looking at my own life
i'm saying you know most of the things
that i hear are positive things i rarely
hear somebody come to tell me michael
this is how i think you should do things
differently if i were you and i'm
telling you this because i really care
about you right
yeah we worked with a senior ge exec
once and and one thing they had
popularized at the time was two simple
words continue or consider
in terms of feedback hey michael i saw
what you're doing there continue to do
that
or michael uh
when you i saw that interaction you
might consider this the next time but as
leaders let's accept the people that
work with us have a lot of pride a
positive pride good pride that they want
to do a great job and they're smart
so if we suggest to them they consider a
different pathway likely they're going
to uh to embrace that
right
i think it's fascinating the the israeli
air force is notoriously known for its
feedback loop and the debriefing
mechanisms and part of the culture is to
accept that you must for every flight
and actually every part of the flight to
to verbally and and
you know in a written form explain what
to continue and what to consider and you
have to give both no matter what even if
they're tiny tiny things like the way
your foot was placed on the brake pedal
whatever you see right in this this idea
that you're embodying here this is
something that that's going to keep me
thinking i think for for a long time
after this episode
mike today you're involved with with a
variety of things specifically around
ignite management services and working
with executives and with leaders what
have you found the best way of working
with others that you're not in their day
to day yet you still want to support
them as they become better executives
and leaders how does this relationship
work
well it all is predicated on trust first
and foremost
um is so that the exercise is one of
building trust and you think we hear the
term rapport i'm gonna say rapport is is
overused
um you have to know michael if you're
gonna work with me that i have your best
interests in my heart
uh and then we set up a cadence let's
speak regularly
uh about um where you're at and where
you want to be
and openly and transparently
there's also a bit of delicacy there
because i i get to work with a range of
executives across the country
and
some are further advanced than others
i i'd have to work with you in the zone
in which you're comfortable and never
stretch you more than say five percent
out of that zone
because
it's an elastic band will break
so my job is to stretch these leaders a
little bit uh to to just outside of
there's all the comfort
and yeah i'm gonna switch gears a little
bit on it and talk about what we really
believe is the pursuit of happiness and
where happiness comes from and we call
it out is when you're working really
hard
at something you're good at
uh that has purpose and meaning those
are first three things
hard good at purpose and meaning with
people you trust who trust you
where you're constantly stretching
yourself out of your comfort zone so we
bring that methodology to our coaching
and that's with teams and with
individuals constantly stretching them
out of their comfort zone it was in the
book flow the psychology of optimal
performance
i loved one of the stories in there
because it comes from where i'm from the
west coast of british columbia where the
uh the squamish nations uh are exist i'm
pretty sure it was the squamish nations
it was a west coast uh first nations
group and the elders michael every
second or third generation would come
with a message to their tribes people
and say
it's time for us to leave
we're going to pack up all of our
belongings and we're going to move and
start from scratch
and you imagine now you've got food
you've got shelter you've got happiness
you've got safety all of these things
are there and you've got this joyous
environment but what the elders knew is
that comfort bread complacency
and
you
they need it to bring people to become
industrious again and that comes back to
our coaching have something you're
working towards always to be the best
version of yourself
i love that story that matter i i become
this idea of
the complacency and
the non-trivial
it's it's incredible and that story is
going to leave with me for a while and
mike i really want to thank you for
really just a fascinating conversation
for me and thinking we're talking you
know there's there's the stretch between
the tangible
day-to-day another theoretical
high-level idea of leadership right and
a lot of times i think that there's you
know this huge gap of misunderstanding
that how to actually apply a lot of
these ideas and and tangibly to thinking
about okay app sitting down for a few
minutes and thinking okay what is my
feedback loop look like who are the
people in my life that are overly caring
that they're not being sharing what they
actually think with me and as a person
who wants to self-improve and be a
better leader how can i
get the people around me to to build
this trust together so that we can have
that common feedback so i'm taking a lot
from this conversation and yeah thank
you very much be careful what you asked
for because i use that with my wife by
says i says honey and you've got to be
more direct with me i need some direct
feedback well she took it to heart
it works michael what a joy it's been to
chat with you and and uh be really
inspiring for me as well
thank you appreciate it take care
thank you so much bye